I guess this is two sides to everybody's
story you know what I mean it's a bit of
a validation thing that you're doing
something right if we create something
and no one likes it they were like well
we're not gonna create that again so why
did you make that decision because
nobody liked it so obviously it matters
at least a little bit but it doesn't
drive what I do it's funny because I
have the same exact opinion you do yeah
but for me I interpreted the question as
like do I take it personally still like
to me it used to matter so much you
still literally be my whole life was
just striving to get more likes more
followers and now I'm in a place where
I'm like I just want to make really cool
stuff that people are excited about I
mean I think it definitely matters in
terms of you know when you're trying to
negotiate brand deals but I also feel
that the relationships that we do build
with our followers is important and I
know that when I was like 13 years old
for example I had an eating disorder and
if I had had a platform like this to
maybe follow or look at other people who
had survived something like that then it
would give me hope
girl being really really young online I
felt this constant pressure to be like a
perfect student a perfect creator a
perfect youtuber and like look perfect
because all these people always had an
opinion on my appearance or the way that
I spoke and I think it's like growing up
into being an adult it's gotten a lot
better but I'm still definitely there
where I constantly feel like I'm overly
cautious of what I say I feel a lot of
responsibility to be a certain way and I
feel like I have to kind of like take
care of my audience even like when it
comes to like my body I'm like in the
gym I'm trying to lose weight like I am
just kind of like striving to be like
better and it is pressure it is I think
just being a creator in general you have
to really own up to who you are as a
person like you have to really see
yourself and know who you are because
when you turn off your phone you know
right away like how you feel like you
feel drained or you feel good about your
work and it's out there for everyone
else to judge as well so you can't help
but judge it yourself I think in a lot
of ways I feel like I have to be perfect
but going off what you said I feel like
the one thing that the Internet has done
to empower me is allow me to be myself
and I feel like the one thing I'm proud
of myself for doing is sharing
everything that I've either done wrong
in my life or that is not perfect and I
feel like that's the only reason why
there's still an audience around me is
because I've been vulnerable the things
I want to be perfect is my camera
quality is the team is my audio you
don't feel pressure no I think I got all
that out of my system
beforehand do you really you are a
separate entity to what you put out no
you don't know you can turn that camera
on it 3 o'clock in the morning at the
same Torrell I swear to God when I say
something it's from my heart it's what I
meant I said what I said don't wide it I
mean that's you but somebody else
somebody else agrees with me yes yes
this is interesting at least for me like
I tried to talk about things I actually
care about and influence things like in
the Asian American community the LGBT
community known to health so I do things
that I really care about and that
matters and I think I'm trying to
influence it even if it just influences
one person you are technically
influencing I guess for me it's like
I've been doing this since I was 16
years old and I'm 24 now so I was doing
this when influencer wasn't a thing and
I remember it was like really hard to
describe what I did to people and then
one day they were like oh so you're an
influencer and I'm like oh but that
person's an influence or two and what I
do looks really different so I feel like
for the lack of words that we have
described things I'm an influencer but I
do a lot more beyond that I somewhat
disagree just because I think it holds
too much of a standard and I think
seeing your this puts me in a box and I
hate that feeling it doesn't make me
feel happy to do what I do so I would
just say like I'm someone who has many
different talents that I'd love to do
many different things and if I happen to
influence someone that's perfect but
it's not what I'm setting out to do
because I'm human just like everyone
else I guess I'm influencing people to
do things but when I post it's more
about for me it's like a platform for
expression so I agree the term
influencer is a little bit totally
foreign for me but I guess this is two
sides to everybody's story you know what
I mean
can we come
without their yeah so I just don't like
the term as in the general sense of the
word but I get that it comes with the
territory
you know people are watching us if
that's part of your creativity that's
part of your creative process you know
what I mean
I don't think photoshopping is selling a
false narrative I just think it's just a
part of an art form I was thinking more
of like making yourself look skinnier
and making yourself look longer like I
think that's like a false image putting
put it out there like I totally agree
with like photoshopping like the
lighting or fixing like a blemish that
your might be insecure about
but I mean I've definitely used faced in
a couple of times so I think that's why
I also disagree with it cuz it's like my
own psyche saying you know you shouldn't
do this you shouldn't be yourself but I
get like in like mainstream media how
everything is photoshopped I just don't
think it's a right to do so because
we're giving a false image of reality
should there be more I guess natural
undoctored images sure but the question
was is it okay it's okay
I knew this question was gonna be here I
hit boom oh when I first started out I'm
gonna be honest it was so cool just to
get free things because I was like wow
like I never thought this would be me
this would be my life like now I feel
like I'm lucky that I have a bigger
audience I can really focus in on what
they deserve to see and what I want to
share I want to promote things that
really don't mean only me but in the
beginning I definitely said yes to
things I kind of regret now I totally
understand what you're saying but me
it's there's a trust factor in terms of
my personal subscribers or whatever I
just feel like if you know they reach
out and then like will you post this
thing like we'll send me the product
first day let me put it on the face we
wake up the next morning mix my face
ain't melted off I wouldn't want you to
try something that I haven't tried I'll
always try it out and if I don't like it
I'm not gonna post at all I didn't come
from getting emailed all the time I
moved here started going to events I
like worked my ass off to like meet the
brand's that I actually liked and work
with them nothing really like came for
me you know
[Music]
there's so many different people from so
many different backgrounds and cultures
and with so many different experiences
all over the world that there's a
message for everyone and it's just a
matter of how you're going to convey
that message now do I think everyone
should be an influencer no but it's
possible I agree with you on that sense
where it's like everyone from any single
walk of life can do that and that's also
the luxury of this influencer space is
that like you didn't need to be born
with a certain parent to get to do it
you didn't have to be born in a certain
neighborhood you didn't have to go to a
certain school but also that being said
I feel like if you want to have a
long-term influence not everybody can do
it because not everybody actually wants
to speak up about things not everybody
wants to put the work in wants to put
the consistency and like being aware and
also like putting the work into the
content where it's like yeah anyone can
do it but it's a hard job the reason I'm
here is because I feel like with the
connotation of the word influencer
people think it's an easy job to get
into it's actually a lot harder because
of the hours you put into it you give up
on yourself a lot you go up and down I
love talking about mental health but the
reason I love doing it is because I
struggle with depression I struggle with
anxiety I grew up with that constant in
my life and I know if I wasn't strong
enough to like know that about myself it
would be so it would be like mentally
damaging for me because it's a lot of
grueling hours by yourself like really
defeating yourself sometimes but you
keep going you don't give up
I feel so lucky that I get to hire who I
want to hire I get to be my own boss I
get to build it into anything I want and
yeah I don't think the most incredible
dream job is just post pictures on
Instagram but I think everything else
that the influencer space has given me I
could not imagine in my wildest dreams I
was like a twelve-year-old what you say
yeah I agree
like the main thing you said Alexa was
be your own boss like something that was
so powerful like I didn't want to work
for other people's dreams anymore like
the nine-to-five working for other
people like I want to work for myself
yeah and I think Instagram is just one
aspect of it like there's so many other
parts to this industry and you really
get to create what you want to be a
creative person
[Applause]
[Music]
I still feel a sense of like this is not
it for me so this is why this is not
just my dream job there's so much more
things that I want to do I want to write
books I want to act for me there's not
just one you're right it is a dream to
be able to manifest the life that you
want and so far I've done that but also
just think like what we do every day we
can touch people's lives at the end of
the day you can say whatever you want to
say and it's gonna like positively
impact somebody if it's from your heart
it's so true and like no one else gets
to do that and we are so lucky like when
I was younger and every set up I want to
be a doctor or a lawyer
I always said I want to help people and
so that's why you're right like this
this is a dream because you get to do
what you love to also help people hey
guys I'm Michael I mean thank you so
much for watching this episode let us
know what you thought in the comments
below follow us on instagram at juggling
media that's where we also post a bunch
of behind the scenes and i'd love to
interact with you guys and hear your
ideas we have a ton more episodes and
we'd love to hear your ideas for those
so yeah see
[Music]